[Musique]
et bien croyez vous qu'il y ait de paca
plus chez nous
crêpes échos votez bien sûr photo
ouattara parce que claude attendant il
nous manque un
[Musique]
tard tu me donnes un bon ben je n'ai pas
le temps je travaille
[Musique]
on ne touchera pas papa si son jour de
pâques à strophes et les mauvaises
humeurs
je m'appelle et la déchirer sa romieu
mapou ben encore une catastrophe ne
pleure pas on en achètera d'eau affectés
par ce choix de carrière sont vides
alors je vais essayer de recoller les
morceaux hip hip hourra ça ils sont
beaucoup de 3,4 mais tout prix fuir la
tête et les pattes h en continu
[Rires]
[Musique]
et
ou vous que de moi
e
[Musique]
et
tiens ma petite patate par chuck je le
choisis pour toi merci partager bien
mignon
c'est que tu les aimes bien je te le
donne moi il ne me rappelais vous est si
gentil pour vous récompenser
je vais vous faire un beau gâteau
pouvait rien
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se passe encore mon gars
donnent à bago fléaux tels abonnés fois
que ça m'arrive je suis déshonoré at à
puce de patache mac ça c'est une vraie
catastrophe
ne vous en faites pas je vais tout
arranger tu vas te mettre la pâtisserie
mais tu n'y connais rien ouais ça c'est
vrai alors un peu de patience
patate truc de pata truc j'ai trouvé le
truc
[Musique]
on
canada revient donc à trop incomplets et
c'était fini c'est dommage il manque un
tout petit peu beurre sucre en deux
couacs au pouvoir réussir le gâteau on
ne sait jamais mais ce n'est pas comme
ça voilà qui n était pas si réussie
[Musique]
moi je ne suis pas fou par les papas
face à la jeune affaire là
[Musique]
acheter un second billet 3g vous qu'il y
ait de pas capuche et ne vous trompez
pas voter bien sûr faux toi at il dit
[Musique]